[Music]
i'm gonna have
you
the fans watching right now produce an
entire episode of our show we are
calling it occupy conan okay
it'll be fun
here's how
here's how occupy conan will work we're
going to post a special best of episode
online your job is to pick one or more
clips from that episode and recreate
them from scratch now the most important
rule is to be creative let your
imaginations run wild i'll give you an
example uh here's a sketch about andy
rounding up an extra audience member
from our show take a look
i just noticed something we have an
empty seat in our audience tonight
there's an empty seat just stay here
we'll keep them busy i'll take care of
it we'll do something hurry
[Music]
emergency
[Music]
and it's so important that you pay
attention to your responsibilities
because it comes from both sides
you absolutely have to
sorry dr phil sorry everyone how are you
doing we're in the middle of the show i
just got to borrow something real quick
could you come with me please
thank you
go back to fixing their problems
all right
that's an actual sketch we did right
here is one of a million different ways
that you could recreate that scene
[Music]
get out of the way
[Music]
and it's so important that you pay
attention to your responsibilities
because it comes from both sides you
absolutely have to
sorry dr phil
we're in the middle of a show no i just
got to borrow something real quick
could you come with me please thank you
go back to fixing their problems
we're assuming
we're assuming that yours will be a lot
better than that and that the andy
richter impression will be much better
uh but here's the idea we'll take bits
and pieces from our favorite entries and
and then we're going to sew them
together into one groundbreaking program
and then we will air that show in our
regular time slot sometime early next
year and you guys will have made it
yeah
now there's another
there's another exciting part of occupy
cone and in keeping with the theme of
recreation the viewer whose submission
is judged best will win the reinvented
volkswagen beetle convertible like the
one andy
is driving in that clip and still is
driving now andy come on in tell us
any uh
andy tell us all about the car sure
thing conan few things in american
culture as original and appreciated as
the classic vw beetle
beetle defined the spirit of rebellion
freedom and fun that everyone wanted in
on
now the all-new volkswagen beetle
convertible adds even more substance
refinement and edge and it's the fastest
beetle ever with an available 200
horsepower turbocharged engine and with
the top down just look how many ping
pong balls you can fit in
[Music]
do you really want me to say the line
yeah yeah say it conan this car has a
lot of balls
[Music]
i'm not paying you if you don't say that
line
[Laughter]
so go to teamcoco.com
occupy conan for all the details i think
this will be a lot of fun we'll be right
back